[Musique]
c'est vrai que vous les attendez les
génies du paf et on va parler des
marseillais puisque la fin de l'aventuré
pour les marseillais se rapproche et
notre ami greg vous savez celui qui est
plus avec qui elle a peur devient telle
émission ils essayent donc d'anticiper
la stratégie des autres candidats pour
deviner si oui ou non il va être éliminé
alors grec se met à faire des calculs
pour comptabiliser les votes en sa
faveur et les votes contre lui le
problème c'est que autant les meufs
voilà greg il connaît autant aux calculs
c'est pas le taux moyen de regarder cet
esprit là j'ai fait une erreur et que ma
famille dans ce mail liminaire bagad moi
et m'a ébahi vote pas contre moi ou pas
gagné moi ma evans battre contre moi et
moi j'ai transporté 12 mois bah ouais
logique tant que les 8 9 mars et donc il
reste 5 5 donc car la naca
kevin comme celle émanant vote moi je
garde de votre corps ouais tu peux la
mettre pour dakar tu mets ta carte de
vote ça lui fait un peu plus un vote un
temps ça lui ferait 4 votes non séparés
non safina s'est pas gêné ce robot a
maintenant des calculs de son côté son
ex nouvelle meuf maeva elle préfère
découvrir la nature qui l'entourent dans
ce nouvel épisode des marseillais maeva
doit réussir à trouver du sel dans les
marais salants
le problème c'est que maeva le solo well
as déjà vu du sel c'est au supermarché
mais comme me voilà alors là la pause
maeva les complètement paumé attention
chez vous cette séquence je vous lis
regardez bien elle est réalisée sans
trucage faire c'est monté entre amis et
tout laisser comme ça
franchement ça me choque new sail à même
le sol en fait moi je pensais que le sel
ça c'est sûr les plantes comme le sucre
sauf que c'est bizarre sa branche de
parterres coutume elle vaque était en
grande forme ça fait plaisir on propose
à maeva de prendre un cours d'équitation
pour apprendre à diriger des chauvauds
sur une calèche
ça peut paraître un peu compliqué comme
ça mais pas pour maeva qui est une
véritable pilote the wall mis en garde
et va d'ailleurs nous expliquer pourquoi
si le patron de m6 nous regarde on a
peut-être trouvé la remplaçante de
dominique chapatte sur tobrouk
[Musique]
ces douches et qui stoppe c'est le ferai
je suis hyper content bien même dans les
voitures et à des chevaux nature je
crois qu'elle a entre chevaux donc là
que 2 du coup mais je vais pouvoir me
débrouiller
[Musique]
les chevaux ils sont dans la boîte
humano ferme
mercredi c'est la journée les enfants
donc c'est hyper important de leur
montrer l'exemple à ne pas suivre
je vous propose donc les pires phrase du
jour de nos amis marseillais regarde
vraiment ce qu un but pas depuis ce
matin on rend compte que cette histoire
ça rime à rien je veux aller lui parler
et là elle me voit pétri kassaraté
l'émoi en place j'ai un gros temps sur
les épaules s'arrêtera morales comprend
rien en fait il sait cheval ils sont
nuls bahia greg qui met toute la facture
moi qui vous reprendre des rêves sauf
que y verras ils vont pas écouté cdd
cheval soit pour qu'ils aient choqué
[Applaudissements]